bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 78
sport c'est parti pour 26 minutes de
direct on passe tout de suite au titre
en image de cette édition il courait
après cette qualification depuis qu
saisons d'au mur plaisir s défit depuis
le Borau ce dimanche pour atteindre les
16e de finales de fédéral 3 spécial à
suivre pendant 3 jours s'est tenue la
seconde édition du M day Paris 22000
amateurs de sensations fortes sétent
donné rendez-vous sur le camp militaire
de Ben pour aller jusqu'au bout de même
immersion cela fait désormais 5 mois que
le vélodrome de 50 ans neline a ouvert
ses porte évidemment une telle structure
à modifier les habitudes des clubs
locaux exemple avec l'équipe cycliste de
véis évidemment en fin d'émission comme
d'habitude tous les résultats du weekend
mais on passe tout de suite à notre page
spéciale rugby
je le disais dans les titres de cette
émission plaisir s'est qualifié pour les
16e de final de fédéral 3 après un
combat de 80 minutes ce weekend ce
dimanche face à Puil Borau et le
l'entraîneur du persc est présent sur le
plateau du 78 sport Philippe Bard
bonsoir à vous et merci d'être là
bonsoir euh une première réaction on va
évidemment voir le résumé complet de de
ce match de ce dimanche euh vous êtes
fier de vos joueurs et de cette
qualification bon c'est évident c'était
quelque chose qu'on attendait depuis bah
depuis 3 ans depuis que je suis arrivé
on a jamais franchi le cap des 32e en se
qualifiant tous les ans cette année on
on y arrive on va jouer un match de
monter et ça c'est une vraie
satisfaction pour tout le monde le le
club en entier alors on va voir comment
cela s'est passé cette courte victoire
on va on va évidemment le dire un 5 à 0
ce ce dimanche face à puilborau après
une courte défaite également au match
alléen de 4 points vous aviez perdu 117
en charante maritime d' mur le PRC
pouvait écrire une page de son histoire
on peut le dire et mettre fin à la
malédiction des 32e de
finale pour croire à la qualification
plaisir se devait de l'emporter face à
pilborau mais sous la pression la
machine jaune et bleu semble s'enrayer
on assiste alors à un brouillon de rugby
des deux équipes entre faute de main et
pénalité raté l'atmosphère devient
irrespirable à Robert Baran comme
souvent cette saison c'est dans le
combat que le PRC va retrouver la
lumière à la demi-heure de jeu les
avants jaunes et bleus pilonent les 22 m
charantais puis le Borau finit par
craquer l'essai n'est pas transformé le
PRC mène 5-0 et s'offre le droit d'y
croire mais c'était sans compter sur la
révolte depuis le Borau qui obtient une
nouvelle pénalité à quelques secondes de
la mi-temps mais le ballon semble ne pas
vouloir passer entre les poteaux une
nouvelle fois en deuxè période la pluie
s'en mê mais pas de quoi perturber les
joueurs de Philippe Bard qui passent en
mode barbelé à un quart d'heure de la
fin du match pu B a une nouvelle
opportunité de débloquer son compteur
mais le pied de l'arrière continue son
récital de pénalité raté et permet à
tout Robert bar de respirer alors qu'il
reste encore quelques secondes à jouer m
introduction
plaisirit pe jaune et bleu le PRC
s'impose 5-0 et met fin la malédiction
des 32e de finale 5- on aurait signé
avant le match ce qu'on disait même 5-
ça nous suffit donc c'est ce qui s'est
passé on n pas réussi à mettre notre
jeens en place mais bon on a été vaant
en défense je pense que voilà
l'essentiel C d'assurer la victoire on
l'a fait aujourd'hui après ça fait 4 ans
qu'on fait 4 ans qu'on échoue à ce
niveau de la compétition on passe un
tour cette anné avec cette équipe c'est
la concrétisation du travail c'est cool
quoi le MOS que l'on puisse dire
Philippe c'est que c'était à l'arracher
ce ce dimanche pour cette qualification
oui je crois qu'on avait deux équipes
qui se valaient qui avait un peu en plus
le même état d'esprit le même style de
jeu et ben dans ces cas-là c'est ça se
joue souvent au match retour quand il y
a pas une grosse différence de points et
ça le fait de jouer chez nous au match
retour c'était un avantage c'est évident
et puis ça se jou au au mental et ben
visiblement ce dimanche on a peut-être
eu un petit un petit plus petit plus que
et et c'est tout une grosse satisfaction
là pour tout le club quoi oui vous avez
senti un petit peu peut-être la peur de
gagner chez vos joueurs ce dimanche ou
pas où ils ont ils ont réussi à être
concentré tout le long des 9 minutes je
je pense que bon vous avez vu le match
qui était pas de GRSE qualité des deux
côtés les deux équipes se crégit le
stress dû aussi à l'événement un
match éliminatoire on fait que beaucoup
d'acteurs qui d'habitude jouer à leur
niveau je pense sont passés un peu à
travers du coup on a eu une un brouillon
de rugby de plus les conditions
atmosphériques vent et pluie par rafale
n'ont pas n'ont pas favorisé non plus le
le beau jeu mais je pense que c'était
plutôt la tension née de l'événement qui
a fait que bah le jeu n'a pas pu se
développer et être aussi plaisant qu'on
aurait aimé le voir à la demi-heure de
jeu vous inscrivez cet essai salvateur
comment vous gérez ça après est-ce que
vous dites il faut qu'on continuer à
engranger des points où justement on va
défendre on va essayer de conserver ce
mince avantage bah déjà
on avait le vent en première mi-temps
donc il fallait marquer le plus de
points possible en première mi-temps
puisqueon savait que la deuxème mi-temps
allit être délicate à 5-0 à la 30e c'est
vrai que c'était court on avait pas
encore pu passer les consignes de la
mi-temps on tourne à 5-0 en 2è mi-temps
bah fallait mettre les barbelet et puis
essayer de jouer des ballons et qu'on
pouvait pas les jouer trop au pied
contre le vent il fallait les porter à
la main et et puis être courageux
solidaire en défense que l'équipe a
toujours su faire tout au long de la
saison quoi mais c'est vrai que la deuxè
mi-temps a quand même été difficile à
vivre quoi c'est c'est sû ce match est
un petit peu à l'image de la saison
c'est une rencontre que vous n'auriez
peut-être pas gagné il y a un an 2 ans
oui on a je pense qu'on a acquis une
certaine solidité
mentale même si on n'est pas très
performant si on a des des lacunes comme
comme
hier dans la conquête dans le jeu au
pieds dans les dans les transmissions
derrière on arrive quand même même en
s'accrochant à défendre charmement notre
peau et puis ben les les valeurs du du
plaisir Rugby Club ressortent dans ces
cas-là et nous permettent de de pas
passer à travers complètement quoi et ce
qui est de bonne augure parce qu'on peut
se dire que le jour où bon ces points là
seront seront réglés ou seront un peu
améliorés on aura des des possibilités
de de jouer un rugby vraiment plus
intéressant et donc de gagner des matchs
contre des grosses équipes quoi ce qu'on
a fait quand même quelques fois dans la
saison il y a eu quelques matchs
références mais c'était pas le cas ce
dimanche et ce par rapport à cette
qualification on a un petit peu
l'impression que ça ça conjure un peu le
mauvais sort parce que ça faisait
quelques années que vous courez après ce
ce stade des 16e de finale ces quatre
saisons voilà le le cap est passé là on
en je pense qu'on était à notre niveau
he sur ces dernières années euh on était
on se qualifiait 3e 4e à la ramasse hein
euh donc on était à notre niveau de
perdre en au au premier tour quand on
rencontra des gross cylindrés comme l'an
dernier ran ou Poitier il y a 2 ans quoi
euh là en finissant dans les deux
premiers ce qui était l'objectif avoué
du club euh on savait qu'on avait
rencontré une équipe qui était qui avait
fini euh au-delà de la 2e place et donc
qui était un peu moins bien classé que
nous et on se devait absolument de de
bah de montrer que on était au moins au
niveau de ces équipes- làà et c'était
l'objectif de la saison de d'obtenir une
qualification pour les 16e puis après
ben on verra on verra c'est c'est du
bonus et justement c'est 16e de finale
euh pour pour ce match aller-retour ce
nouveau match aller-retour vous allez
croiser la route de chat chre une équipe
que vous connaissez bien puisque ils
étaient dans votre poolle sur cette
saison régulière comment vous voyez
cette double confrontation c'est
toujours c'est on était très content de
jouer les 32e contre une éip qu'on
connaissait pas avec un vrai déplacement
qui qui ça ressemblait vraiment à des f
finales team là bon on va retrouver une
équipe de la poule qu'on a battu deux
fois donc c'est à double tranchant je
pense c'est une équipe qui finit la
saison vraiment très fort et puis qui a
des grosses individualités ils ont un
budget important qui leur a permis de de
d'avoir des rentrées de joueurs
étrangers en particulier des des
Britanniques à des postes clés et c'est
vrai qu'il y a des grosses
individualités derrière ça sera les deux
matchs contre nous ont été des matchs
très serrés puisqu'on gagne d'un point
chez eux même si on fait un bon match au
retour on gagne que de 10 ou 12 points
je crois donc ça sera ça sera deux
matchs délicats contre une équipe qu'on
connaît c'est le seul avantage ça veut
dire qu'on va pouvoir grâce à la vidéo
bah retrouver tous les points forts et
les points faibles de cette équipe et
bosser c'est pour préparer au mieux
l'équipe cette semaine et ce qu'il faut
dire c'est que surtout en cas de
victoire et de qualification c'est la
fédérale 2 qui va s'offrir à plaisir et
ça c'est une vraie étape ouai
c'est bon on va pas y penser jusqu'à
jusqu'à ce que ça soit arrivé mais si
jamais ça arrivait ça serait quelque
chose de très nouveau quoi le club a été
en fédéral 2 mais il y a au moins une
trentaine d'années euh c'est un autre
monde hein moi je je je le connais un
petit peu et ça nécessite euh des
structures des des finances et un
investissement des joueurs plus
important que ce qu'on ce qu'on a dans
un club comme plaisir quoi donc il
faudra
réfléchir se convaincre qu'on peut faire
quelque chose c'est-à-dire dans les
premier temps s'y maintenir si jamais ça
se présentait c'est vrai que ça serait
une un peu une révolution au club de
plaisir comment vous allez préparer
justement ce cette double confrontation
contre chartre cette semaine je pense
que on va récupérer déjà parce que c'est
des matchs durs ces matchs de phase
finale et puis on est au bout d'une
saison longue on a eu une poule de 11
donc ça veut dire qu'on a eu plus de
matchs que que les les autres équipes
voilà donc la saison elle est longue
c'est un peu le même groupe de joueurs
qui qui tourne depuis le début de la
saison donc ça va être de la récupe et
puis travail sur les de précision sur
les choses qui ont qui bah qui n'ont pas
été à la hauteur ce dimanche et sur de
tris dimanches dernier dimanche en
particulier la conquête et et le jeu au
pied il va falloir vraiment améliorer si
on veut faire quelque chose contre cette
équipe très bien merci beaucoup Philippe
d'être passé sur le 78 sport évidemment
on va suivre ça de près premier match
donc match aller face à char de ces 16e
de finale de Fédérale 3 peut-être pour
s'entrouvrir on va dire un coin de porte
pour pour la fédéral 2 merci beaucoup
Philippe merci
bonsoir Cela fait désormais 5 mois que
le vélodrome de 50 ans en yeline a
ouvert ses portes évidemment une telle
structure à modifier les habitudes des
clubs cyclistes locaux c'est notamment
le cas de véizi de dossier réalisé avec
Patrick Jacques de
dixmud désormais tous les samedis matins
les cyclistes vézéens se réunissent sur
la piste si l'équipe cycliste de véisi
créée en
1970 reste un club de route par
tradition avec l'ouverture du Vélodrome
un pôle piste a été rapidement créé
l'ouverture du Vélodrome nous a apporté
une une cohésion déjà l'intérêt pour la
piste et cela a permis à une quinzaine
de coureurs de ouvrir la piste en tant
que débutant et maintenant ils sont ils
sont passés au stade de confirmer et
puis ça crée une émulation il y a 5 mois
le champion d'Europe master du kilomètre
Yan du jarier devait préparer les
échéances internationales avec les
moyens du bord depuis janvier dernier
l'ouverture du Vélodrome il n'a que
quelques minutes de trajet pour venir
s'entraîner depuis cette année c'est
c'est un réel plaisir de puis se poser
la question de savoir regarder la météo
pour venir à l'entraînement on vient
vraiment quand on a envie les horaires
sont très flexibles avec des horaires
très tôt le matin pour ceux qui
travaillent travaillent dans la journée
ceux qui peuvent venir en coupure entre
MH et 2 c'est nous ça nous est
accessible le soir 20h 22h ou 18h 22h
selon les jours c'est génial depuis
janvier les PISTAR rivelinois ont pu
découvrir les vertus formatrices de la
piste et réaliser des exercices
spécifiques l'anneau de Saint-Quentin
c'est aussi le moyen idéal d'attirer
plus de jeunes vers la pratique du vélo
pour un club qui compte aujourd'hui 80
licenciers depuis que je suis revenu au
club je m'occupe justement de
l'entraînement des jeunes sur la route
et euh bon c'était c'était toujours un
peu difficile parce que c'est pas la
même distance c'est pas les mêmes
intensités et et c'est vrai que là de
pouvoir les accompagner sur le sur un
vélodrome ça va être génial parce que
ben moi je pourrais faire mes intensités
en leur en expliquant d'autres pour eux
et on aura vraiment le même outil on
roulera sur 250 m l'objectif pour cette
quinzaine de coureurs véiséens
participer aux futures compétitions
nationales et international à commencé
par le championnat d'île-defance France
le 30 mai prochain je vous en parlais
dans les titres de cette édition pendant
3 jours c'est tenue la seconde édition
justement du mday Paris les amateurs de
sensation fortes sétaient donné
rendez-vous dans les ivelines sur le
camp militaire de Ben et pour aller
surtout jusqu'au bout de même immersion
avec Olivier
Maniscalco
sur 13 km et 22 obstacles le menu du mod
Day est simple de l'eau de l'électricité
de la glace mais surtout de la boue de
la boue de la
boue au milieu des 6000 participants du
jour Marianne Guillaume et Thierry ont
plongé avec une dizaine d'amis dans
l'enfer de la boue malgré la pluie ces
modur doivent passer les obstacles coûte
que coûte à la manière des commandos
d'unité d'élite esprit d'équipe et
survie deviennent alors indissociaable
il aentraide aussi parce que c'est une
course qu'on peut pas faire si on
sentraide pas ouis il y aentraide au
sein de notre équipe et puis aussi avec
les autres participants des gens qui
demandent s'ils peuvent aider si tout va
bien donc ça c'est un côté très
sympathique si Thierry franchit les
premiers obstacles sans encombre la boue
du M réserve par fois de mauvaises
surprises et au moment où on s'y attend
le moins j'étais après les sauts debout
qu'il fallait soulever et sur un chemin
plat j'étais en train de marcher en plus
normalement et j'ai glissé et j'ai
essayé de me rattraper et mon pied a
fait craque je pense que c'était pas les
bonnes chaussures surtout ouais je pense
c'est des baskets et les chaussures de
marche été bien meilleur les
participants sont sont sont plutôt très
contents ils sont pas mal fatigués hein
surtout les les derniers qui arrivent
maintenant ils ont eu assez froid mais
c'est le jeu on est là pour on est là là
pour faire mal tout ça dans une bonne
ambiance pour lui le mod day s'arrête là
mais sans aucun doute il reviendra se
frotter à la boue de leur côté après
2h30 en enfer pas de chronomètre ni de
classement pour Marian et Guillaume car
au mode day participé est déjà un
exploit cette semaine le billard club
vissinois a fêté ses 20 ans en cadeau le
club s'est vu remettre une nouvelle
salle dans le quartier de La Bretonnière
et pour l'occasion le numéro 2 mondial
de la discipline n'a plus proposé aux
chanceux spectateurs une démonstration
assez spectaculaire reportage réalisé
avec Olivier
Maniscalco créé en 1993 par quelques
passionnés de la commune dans le premier
adjoint du maire de l'époque le billard
club vcinois fait aujourd'hui ses 20 ans
d'existence à l'époque installé à
l'espace de Coville et équipé de
seulement quatre billards le club a bien
grandi il inaugurait d'ailleurs ce simé
sa nouvelle salle dans le quartier de La
Bretonnière avec désormais 70 L ci h
tables flambon neuv le billard se
démocratise à voisin le Bretonneux et
être un sport tout public c'est
d'ailleurs une de ces particularité
c'est une des caractéristiques du
billard que d'être accessible à la fois
aux jeunes où la limite c'est simplement
la taille on va dire et puis aux anciens
puisque c'est un sport où on peut jouer
très longtemps et on peut même
progresser jusqu'à une
date fort sympathique on va dire
pourévénement club recevait la visite de
Madame le Maire et d'un champion mondial
de billard TR bandes un champion qui a
pu proposer une petite
démonstration je joue dans plusieurs
clubs alors il y a des des très très Bux
club aussi mais 20 ans c'est un bon
temps jouer avec les joueurs du club et
tout ça c'est c'est très arable c'est
intéressant pour moi pour eux aussi je
pense avec ses nouveaux équipements le
club est maintenant disposé à accueillir
un public plus nombreux pour les 20
prochaines années 20 prochaines années
que le billar club vcinois espère aussi
belle que Cell qui viennent de
s'écouler allez on passe à l'essentiel
des résultats du
weekend une fois n'est pas coutume on
commence par du football et ce weekend
se jouaient les demi-finales de de la
coupe des Yvelines et vous allez le voir
carrière grisillon s'est imposé trois
buts à deux sur le terrain du chînet de
son côté hardardri cour c'est défit de
houille 3 à 0 rendez-vous donc pour la
finale le 15 juin prochain entre
hardardriour et carrière Grésillon en
tennis 2e journée du championnat de
France par équipe chez les hommes
l'équipe première de plaisir s'est
incliné à la roche suryon 4 matchs à
deux et conforte sa première place
malheureusement de son côté l'équipe 2 a
été disqualifiée sur cette 2è journée
d'où ce score vous le voyez de 4 à 0
face à uning chez les femmes plaisir
toujours en National uneb c'est incliné
4-2 sur les cours de hutegaron à
Saint-Jean toujours sans victoire cette
saison les plaisiroises sont désormais
4e de leur poule un une autre info pour
continuer c'est du vélo aigu enco
organisé ce weekend son 28e prix
cycliste 220 coureurs étaient au départ
sur l'ensemble des deux courses à guyan
courour le circuit de 2 km est assez
plat il faut le dire le son etemi du
cycliste c'est le vent et les risques de
bordure pendant la course de nombreux
coureurs ne loupent évidemment pas ce
rendez-vous cquantinois cela devient
presque une question d'honneur de
s'imposer sur ces terr un succès rendu
plus difficile à cause des fortes
averses depuis ce weekend la chaussée
était donc très glissante la priorité
était évidemment de finir la course pour
l'ensemble du
Ploton rester sur sur le
vélo avec les condition i les rafales de
vent et la pluie ça va être compliqué
c'est toujours sympa de courir voilà
déjà je suis gu courtois donc courir à
côté à la maison c'est toujours sympa là
il y a quand même pas mal de d'amis et
tout qui courent aussi ensemble c'est
c'est une bonne ambiance oui en hand bal
ce weekend National 2 féminine
évidemment et pour le compte de la 21e
journée montinier recevait le 7e bovvet
les in montaines se sont imposés plutôt
tranquillement 27 à 21 les ctinoises
conservent leur 6e place au classement
une image de poker à présent pendant 4
jours le vélodrome de 50 ans en yeline a
accueilli 2000 joueurs l d'un tournoi
international associatif une première
mondiale il faut le dire organisé par le
club de poker de voisin le Bretonneux et
avec une particularité les joueurs ne
pouvaient pas gagner d'argent sur
l'ensemble du tournoi 400 jeux de cartes
et 36000 jetons tenez-vous bien ont été
distribués au milieu des amateurs
certains joueurs professionnels avaient
fait le déplacement pour réaliser
quelques foules ou encore quelques
quinfloches royal
j'apprends pas mais par contre je suis
toujours ça m'arrive encore d'être
surpris de des joueurs amateurs du bon
comme du mauvais côté c'est des fois
j'ai je trouve des fois qu'ils sont
certains sont à très bon niveau et
d'autres des fois j'ai du mal à
comprendre où est leur logique
finalement une dernière information
avant de passer à l'agenda de la semaine
l'agenda sport un grand bravo au jeunes
U13 les moins de 13 ans de l'Entente
Sportive de Guill enc qui se sont
qualifiés ce weekend tenez-vous bien
pour la finale nationale du challenge
Henry Guérin c'est l'équivalent de la
Coupe de France pour les seniors
évidemment c'est une première dans
l'histoire du club bravo à eux nous
passons évidemment à l'agenda du weekend
et surtout de la semaine puisqu'il y a
deux événements à ne pas rater cette
semaine tout d'abord du cyclisme ce
mercredi 14 mai vous pourrez assister à
la Coupe de France de l'Américaine tout
l'après-midi ouverture des portes du
Vélodrome pour le public à partir de 12h
c'est la première édition sur l'anneau
cinquantinois il y aura du tir à l'arc
également cette fois-ci c'est ce weekend
dimanche 18 mai Montini accueille le
championnat départemental de tir fédéral
plus de 250 archers se défieront sur du
tir à 50 50 m début des hostilités à 9h
ce dimanche au stade de La Coudre c'est
la fin de ce 78 sport merci de l'avoir
suivi on se retrouve lundi prochain même
heur comme d'habitude je vous souhaite
une excellente soirée sur
TVfil